all right before we get started i want
to thank the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for the creative
and the curious really creative stuff to
explore and learn here everything from
film and video
photography creative writing animation
and music and if you were ever curious
about that p90 joke i cracked
in my video about the justice league
joker well skillshare has learn guitar
the complete beginner's guide you can
start the path to knowing my p90 joke's
a bit better and to me it's like
learning to play an instrument
is like learning a language you didn't
know
you really needed to know and skillshare
is curated for your learning experience
which means no ads they don't flood you
with those ads it's just
creative discovery for less than ten 10
a month and the first 1 000 of my
subscribers to click the link below will
get a free premium trial membership to
explore that creativity
that calls to you so click the link
below get started on that path of
discovery that calls to you and thank
you once again to skillshare for
sponsoring this video
i do appreciate it and now mortal kombat
it's happening we have a trailer okay i
guess this is real i'm not gonna lie
it's pretty sweet yeah sometimes the
visual effects you're like oh yeah it
looks like a youtube movie for sure but
it looks to be made by someone who wants
to have the spirit of mortal kombat
alive
trailer starts out at sonia talking
she's like yeah we ran across this guy
who can just freeze [ __ ] which right
there when i saw that scene where jax
has the shotgun to sub-zero and he
shoots the shotgun and the buckshot just
freezes mid arrows like that's pretty
slick that you know
sub-zero freezes tracks his arms and
shatters him that's how jax loses his
arms in here i guess irmak wasn't
available for the role he's a busy guy
has a lot to do
he is many there but one but this movie
kind of in its way looks to be something
i've wanted to see in mortal kombat like
i always thought
it'd be cool to have a mortal kombat
cinematic universe i know
i've kind of bagged on the fact that
everything feels like it has to be a
cinematic universe these days
but i feel like mortal kombat really
lends itself to that like example you
could have a sonja jax movie and they're
going after kano and that somehow leads
across
sub-zero and then the next movie is a
sub-zero scorpion backstory movie you
have these movies that are cool
adventures they build up the characters
and then the avengers movie where they
all come together is the mortal kombat
tournament movie it looks like it's that
but one movie you got sonja jacks going
across sub-zero you have sub-zero
scorpion conflict you have the greatest
character in mortal kombat history
cole who the who's cole i don't want to
be pessimistic but it ain't looking good
for my man
cole over here he is going into mortal
combat a super bloody death tournament
filled with fatalities decapitations
arms getting shattered
hearts getting ripped out and his name
is cole otherwise known as character
who's not in the games
i feel like cole should be wearing a red
star trek uniform at this point art
leans over there going yeah you're
[ __ ] buddy trust me
just trust me and yeah we're gonna joke
a little more about poor king cole that
line about his birthmark i feel like
peter dinklage from avengers infinity
war should have a cameo
just for that line it's a birthmark what
do you mean
he was born with it yes that's what
birthmark means but it's not a birthmark
it's a mark he's had
since birth that means he's been chosen
which technically is still a birthmark
it's just a birthmark that means you've
been chosen i will say i miss
kari hiroyuki tagawa as shang tsung i
think it would have been a good
opportunity for him to be old
shang soon i was gonna say i haven't
seen that but technically i have because
he was in the second season of mortal
kombat legacy as old shang tsung but you
know i feel like i'm gonna miss him but
this
dude at least from the one shot in the
trailer the one line he has
i think he looks awesome there's a scene
where it's like a statue of shao khan
he looks like shao khan from mortal
kombat 11. also a quick
shot of molina which some people there
were character poses people like dude
were her teeth i'll hold out on that i
want to reserve judgment until i see how
they actually
do molina past one character poster or
one shot i mean it could be a pennywise
thing to have going on was like oh looks
normal she opens her mouth it's like
maybe not that intense but you know what
i mean also kano that's another one i
wanna i wanna see how they do
because not only i mean kano doesn't
have his robot eye i mean he has a robot
eye it's like he has terminator eye
when terminator just took a little bit
of battle damage you know his eyes red
couple scrapes but he doesn't have the
full like terminator costume piece that
they put on
richard davizio's eye to make him look
like kano in the original game but with
that who knows maybe as the movie goes
on he takes battle damage and starts
peeling away and then you get the
volcano eyepiece but with kano trailers
being trailers the trailer doesn't
really illustrate that sonia and kano
are better enemies
there's a couple of scenes where they're
in the same scene together kind of
shoulder to shoulder in the same group
looks like they're questing together i
mean i don't know if they are when
sonja's rattling off the names like i'm
sonya that's jax
that's cole he'll die that's kano it's
like
are they on a team then again the way
audio and trailers are cut together it
could be a scene where she's like that's
kano get him they just cut it like
that's kano welcome to the team cole
grant it does show
sonia and kano fighting in one scene i'm
saying it doesn't look like they're
better enemies it doesn't look like
sonya necessarily wants to kill him
as he is her mortal enemy but this being
the story that leads to the tournament
what happens in this movie could lead to
them being those better enemies
you know as backstories go also love the
casting of hiroyuki sonata
as hanzo assange because he always has
that intensity to him you know he
usually plays a good
guy but always that intense good guy
when i heard he was cast as scorpio and
hanzo
sasha i was like that's kind of perfect
casting the thing that drew me into
mortal kombat as a kid was scorpion the
scorpion sub-zero conflict it looks like
this movie
really concentrates on that a lot plays
that up although sub-zero doesn't move
in here
i think it's more of a scarlet move
myself but are they going to show the
fatalities
in a trailer if you see that red band at
the beginning of the trailer
they are yeah it's such a montage of
death destruction
and fatalities that i'm like i kind of
don't want to see it i want to save it
for the movie
i get you want to pitch people like hey
this is mortal kombat this is mortal
kombat prime but i'd you know save some
for the screen though it's pretty sweet
that kano rips out a heart
so yes i woke up to news of a mortal
kombat trailer
saw the mortal kombat trailer and i
enjoyed the mortal kombat trailer
alright so the trailer for the new
mortal kombat movie not just coming this
year
but next two months from now april
what month is this have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you